hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to until dawn I finally
finally got done playing through the
entire game again yes I spent a whole
day doing that I have not spent a whole
day of just playing a game in a long
time but I was trying my best to follow
this walkthrough and there were some
parts where it made the wrong choices
and I missed some stuff or I did some
stuff in the wrong order so I have
almost all the clues for the twins I
imagine there's two more left at the end
of the game I have almost all the 1952
clues except for one I don't know where
I missed it it seems like it would have
been pretty obvious but I missed it I
have all of the mystery man clues which
is jaws and the reason I do that I'll
explain I also have all the totems I'll
get to that in a second but here's where
things go different between my
playthrough now and my playthrough
before it's not really all that much the
butterfly effect is not that severe so
the bird is still alive
I actually didn't snoop in Chris's
backpack I didn't tell Matt to look
through the telescope to look at Mike
and Emily being all together still sided
with Emily still was a hero I didn't
even need to use the bat because when
Sam was being chased I did all the right
choices and therefore she didn't even
get kidnapped I did chase after Jessica
that's still the same I didn't even get
Mike's fingers cut off because you
actually don't need to go up to that
machine with the waving hand if it
wasn't obvious enough like a red flag
that a waving decrepit rotting hand was
bad news I I didn't go up to it alright
Wolf's still the same this time I gave
the flare gun to Matt but Matt fired it
off right away I've like an idiot I have
no idea why run or hide like I said Sam
did everything just right to hide away
from the killer everything was good
there Matt had the gun
but Emily had no defense against the
attack which was fine because that's
what happen anyway even when Emily did
have it I don't know why she didn't use
it before Matt is still alive because he
saved himself so he jumped to safety
still stabbed this time Ashley did see
the psycho in the workshop that was an
important clue to know that Josh was the
killer and when Sam was by herself she
actually walked through josh's workshop
and saw that he was going through a lot
of psychiatric treatment and was
actually off his meds
before he got here I'll actually I might
show you that clue so everything up into
that point is the same except for the
fact that everyone including Ashley is
still alive
now I didn't read too far ahead in the
tutorial I didn't read to chapter 10 but
I did get to the end of chapter 9 in
Chapter 9 said that you're actually
supposed to follow that voice you're
just not supposed to open the door with
the big blaring warning sign saying open
you idiot I haven't looked at chapter 10
I intentionally did not so there's still
the possibility that everyone can die in
a horrible horrible way because I'm an
idiot but until that point comes I am
just gonna try my best to keep everybody
alive there we go here does I think yeah
it is it what do we got here did I pick
this one up before I have no idea yep
yeah I picked that up before
okay that's Josh I'm assuming if he
resorted to cannibalism and turns into a
horrible monstrosity which would be bad
oh no poor Josh nah and this one Josh
pretty much did the same but now that we
like have gotten all the evidence it did
change some outcomes in the dialogue
what they were talking about so I don't
know how long it'll affect it but it
will Chris thought he was gonna slow us
down but I'm the one going slow it's
almost as if I come from the future
bearing knowledge of which you guys do
not understand I don't think there's
anything else here by the way okay so
I'm pretty sure I can go through to it
I'm sure they're not death waiting on
the other side I'm gonna fast-forward
till we try it
Naomi I'm now the monster sounds
convincing I should go down there
actually I should go down there because
there's a totem there that I need wait
there we go haha butterfly effect update
let's hope that death doesn't happen I
know it's crazy why would you go down
there there's no reason to do so Jessica
is that you yeah of course it is well I
mean the Wendigos name could be Jessica
you have no idea could theirs be a crazy
coincidence yeah it does sound a bit
more convincing now that I'm listen to
it again of course I don't really
remember I tried to blot out all those
memories poor Josh look at Josh man okay
so my theory on this by the way I'm
pretty sure I mentioned it before but my
theory on this is that Hannah is one of
the one that goes there's more than one
Wendigo but Hannah is one of them and
I'm willing to bet that somehow that
specific scenario is gonna come into
play so screw that screw that screw that
a million ways God screw that yeah okay
so we should be able to just go over
here go over here and rejoin the group
that we don't need to let the wind go in
oh man again yep we're all fine I was
that close to making that choice I would
have been totally okay and yet I screwed
up bad bang bang
[Music]
do it it's like the rock wall yeah okay
really loose oh okay all right cool cool
cool great choice is great splitting up
now we're splitting into three groups
this is the best okay
what is this I don't know what's
happening here oh that's right this is
what it was going to either I was
freaking out
I think we're leaning in a Josh I
believe because when I paused it was
Josh's face on the screen so we need to
find out what's going on with Josh
probably bad things I would imagine
collarbone broken hip broken shoulder
dislodged all sorts of bad stuff Oh are
we not oh we're not playing him oh good
okay at least he's alive I suppose if we
are happy about that I'm not sure okay
we need to leap cuz I'm a badass come on
well easy easy nope gotcha
you're gonna die on me this time Sam
nothing you died before but I mean this
time you leap leap you little pansy come
on you got it
dig deep be a badass be a baller there
you go oh okay you got you got that one
without me apparently
good job good team effort great going
there yeah you beat him something okay
now what okay so I got to pay really
close attention to things here because
there's probably a lot of Secrets and I
just want to make sure that I get them
all because if I miss any at this point
it could cost me more than I know
because you never know when these things
are gonna okay so nothing here nothing
here nothing here I just have to be as
thorough as I possibly can because I'm
flying blind now okay what is that over
there oh okay don't drop down yet
instead of there store up there
we're here hello I'm just okay that's
not good
can I not go back now oh crap I didn't
explore anything how's I supposed to
know oh um it was a couple of mean it
was a big old kaboom
that was probably Mike having fun with
the explosives I'm willing to bet anyway
damn it tonight am I not able to go back
see the problem now is I don't know I
don't know which way is like the way
forward and I don't know which way is
the way to go get stuff this looks like
maybe okay what are we what do we got
what is this
hello alright we'd already encountered
this didn't I okay maybe I did I have no
idea
ah there we go totem totem totem okay
yes yes I don't know why that other
thing wasn't a clue maybe that's
something I already found before final
death totem okay that seems bad how do I
avoid that you didn't give me a lot of
details because that seems to be the
right of now the immediately now-ish oh
boy I don't like that a lot
so there's a correct way to go on the
wrong way okay it's probably something
obvious maybe I don't know how would I
know
how would I know I just got it not open
any trapdoors and screaming
cool now where am I see this place to
fall in the park Oh God
oh gosh oh gosh oh yes oh yes oh yes
sure
oh yes yeah get the pipe I like the pipe
the pipe school hit things with the pipe
okay got the pipe cool oh that don't
sound good that sounds like the opposite
of good I know a lot of good things that
doesn't look good okay so I got the pipe
am i back to where I was before or did I
just do the drop down I think I'm back
to where maybe I'm back to where I was
before yeah no no no definitely not
where the hell am I now god damn it
keep getting turned around and lost I
have a feeling
[Applause]
[Music]
all right fine all right
alive or start yay laughs good lives
good how are you doing here anyway let's
find a way down to where this [ __ ]
lives yep
oh okay all right well I didn't try to
take a screenshot you dick okay here we
go here we go oh hey how's it going
things are getting pretty bad huh
just a little bad huh
I wonder how much these sessions are a
been healthy enough just won't listen to
me and think seems pretty
[ __ ] Thanks so I'm gonna leave you
now Josh it's time to burn very small to
be afraid of that can be trapped up by
the unhinged imagination of a
self-indulgent spoiled little brat
you had so many people who cared about
you
we're willing to help but at every turn
you choose to push them away
[Music]
deep breath enjoy thanks dr. hill
you have a good one now how much do I
owe you for that self confidence booster
[Music]
okay whoa okay now if they wanted to
make a good [ __ ] game maybe they should
have made it from the perspective of
Joss as he slowly becomes more and more
unhinged throughout the game now that
would be an interesting interesting game
okay either way so now I have to be very
thorough about this but the only problem
is I'm in complete darkness I have no
idea what's going on or where I'm doing
how would I know I can't see a damn
thing
[Music]
we were all alone down there hi okay
you're with us now family why don't you
save us Josh why did you want us to talk
[Music]
goddamn seriously oh boy oh that ain't
good
oh that ain't good oh that ain't
yeah
[Applause]
holy crap Wow
what the hell so you seen it before what
are you talking about all these old
pictures of some guys with that scar and
he was transforming into a Wendigo
uh-huh
we're now miners have been trapped back
in the 50s in the cave in which means
that thing is 80 years old at least
it's bunkie for an old-timer they
cleaned the place out killed a lot of
people they come in there are more of
them oh yeah
how many too many
[Music]
how did that how did that guy with the
flamethrower go through this whole thing
rounding up all those things and then
die oh well I'm just making sure I'm
backtracking a little bit just in case
it was like a thing or something because
this is a long way to backtrack whoa
wait was I supposed to go this I don't
think I wasn't go this way we just came
for this way I just want to make sure I
have to be thorough okay all right I
think we're good
don't mind my leg I think we're good
okay I just have to be thorough I can't
miss a damn thing now I have to be
diligent at all times okay I mean even
when I've been diligent I've noticed
that when I was playing through it again
I still missed stuff Oh screw you
there's no other way through you go
first I ain't going in there
you haven't even checked if there's
another way through it's probably
millions oyster what was like a crane
ooh
[Music]
Oh Beth watch I mean we knew that Beth
was dead because we found her head okay
so they dug your grave yes wait those
across here cuz it was across somewhere
else is this the same play this can't be
the same place can it is it or maybe the
cross was just moved later on I have no
idea
all right so that was one thing I don't
think there's anything else wait I only
have one other I think I only have one
other yeah okay there's only one other
thing so the next thing I'm gonna find
is gonna be the last one I got to be on
the lookout for that I've got nothing
else on the 1952 okay so there's only
one more thing and there's only four
more totems and I'm pretty sure I
haven't missed any of those so I gotta
get all of them - to get all of them
alright okay here we go oh oh it's right
there oh my god I would have missed that
oh man I almost miss that whew alright
yeah okay
Fortson told him the whole house is on
fire so are we gonna burn the whole
[ __ ] down to try to break this curse
is that what we're gonna try to do I
don't know probably all right so that
must be everything okay so now we're
good fine all right
probably not a good idea oh no thanks
thanks famous last words are also famous
last words okay on the lookout very cold
oh my goodness oh oh there's something
over there wait
Mike's going one way but there's
something over here yeah yeah yeah this
is important this is important this is
important
Oh music don't pick up on me now wait no
crap okay wait ah my little sisters oh
my god my little sister is dead the fall
killed her I watched the color drained
from her face my leg is broken I'm all
alone stuck here with Beth it's his body
someone will come I've never been so
hungry it feels like my stomach is
twisting around inside
I took Beth sweater much warmer now
she's still looking out for me I'm sorry
Beth I have no choice I'm dying
so what mindfulness I'm sorry I had to
have no choice as a name
she ain't Beth oh my god day 30 that's
how long she held out my hands feel
unclean my nails fell out pushed out
I am aching but no more cold no pain I
am getting stronger
[Music]
that's no half good damn time Beth have
bad time no that's Michael it has to be
the only thing that makes sense
Beth died in fall
so what where's Evie so Hanna must have
buried her damn it Hanna was down here I
don't believe any of this starving she
would have been desperate
[ __ ] we need to find Josh right now
okay so I'm assuming that it's important
because now now that they know I knew
but now they know so if they know that
means they can tell other people and
that can infect this story that's what's
important about that okay now they know
good goody goody gumdrops okay all
righty then
okay let's just get through this get
through this next part let's get through
this a little more okay don't die don't
die no doc okay you're old sir
stop being such babies wait okay I just
want to make sure let me double check
okay got that got that got that got that
three more left okay loss danger for
Jack okay I think I got everything okay
pretty sure I'm pretty sure we made it
we made it we made it okay we're good
we're good we're good good good good
good good good good good good
okay all right are we now okay that says
danger on it we should walk towards it I
can't wait to do that thing that I don't
want to do okay all right okay all right
okay cool oh there's something on the
ground over was this no no no don't do
that I said there was something on the
ground why wasn't there like a drop it
why just wanted to get another dip in
why not just for funsies that's just in
case you need to go back for any
particular reason
okay hey that's enough for me okay I
guess we can there we go okay all right
so we're back on track I'm pretty sure
I'm gonna finish up this game in just
one more episode here thank you
everybody so much for joining me we're
on the right path we're gonna do great
and without it the walk over to the hood
bird dies
I just want actually his Christmas love
to continue so thank you everybody so
much for watching and
always I will see you in the next video
that's how you're gonna play this game
any game baby I'm home come out and
scooty oh boy
yeah nothing